>>> THIS JUST IN TO CNN --
DONALD TRUMP'S TWITTER ACCOUNT
IS BACK.
ELON MUSK REINSTATED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT JUST MINUTES AGO.
THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
TWITTER PAGE HERE.
UNTIL TONIGHT IT HAD SAID
ACCOUNT SUSPENDED.
EARLIER TONIGHT, MUSK POSTED A
POLL ON TWITTER ASKING IF PEOPLE
THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE
ALLOWED BACK ON THE SERVICE.
MUSK SAYS THE RESULTS SHOWED
THAT PEOPLE WANTED TRUMP TO
RETURNMENT HE TWEETED THIS --
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN, TRUMP
WILL BE REINSTATED.
VOX POPILI, MEANING THE VOICE OF
THE PEOPLE, THE VOICE OF GOD.
TWITTER'S PREVIOUS MANAGEMENT
SUSPENDED TRUMP INDEFINITELY
DAYS AFTER THE JANUARY 6th
CAPITOL INSURRECTION.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN CNN MEDIA
ANALYST AND MEDIA REPORTERS FOR
AXIOS SARAH FISHER.
WITH US NOW ON THE PHONE.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
TWITTER HERE IN THE LAST HOUR OR
SO.
THIS BIG DEVELOPMENT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS NEWS?
>> WELL, I'M ACTUALLY SURPRISED.
PER OUR CONVERSATION EARLIER I
THOUGHT ELON MUSK WOULD WAIT
UNTIL FACEBOOK MADE THE CALL IN
JANUARY.
IT SEEMS HE WAS EAGER TO MOVE
FORWARD.
HE DID THIS TWITTER POLL.
MANY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE VOTED.
AND THE LAST TIME I CHECKED, IT
WASN'T REALLY A WIDE MARGIN, IT
WAS ABOUT 52% OF PEOPLE WHO
VOTED IN THE POLL SAID THAT
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE
REINSTATED.
AND ELON MUSK MOVING QUICKLY AS
HE DOES, VERY QUICKLY REINSTATED
DONALD TRUMP AFTER THAT POLL.
>> YEAH, I MEAN THIS IS A
TWITTER POLL, RIGHT, THIS IS NOT
A SCIENTIFIC POLL.
THIS IS AN ONLINE POLL.
AND SO TO BORROW A QUESTION FROM
MY COLLEAGUE OLIVER DARCY, HE
SAID WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
CONTENT MODERATION COUNCIL THAT
MUSK SAID, YOU KNOW, ONLY LAST
MONTH HE'D BE INSTITUTING?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
EARLIER HE HAD ALREADY
INSTITUTED ACCOUNTS THAT WERE
PERMANENTLY BANNED INCLUDING
KATHY GRIFFITH, AUTHOR JORDAN
PETERSON, THE BABYLON BEE, HE
HAD BEEN FORESHADOWING THIS MOVE
OF REINSTATING ACCOUNTS, MAKING
POLICY DECISIONS WITHOUT THE
COUNCIL.
I CAN'T SAY I'M TOTALLY
SURPRISED THAT HE'S DOING IT
UNILATERALLY NOW.
BUT IT DOES BRING INTO QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT ELON MUSK IS
GOING TO GOVERN BY THE HIP
MOVING FORWARD DESPITE PROMISING
ADVERTISERS HE WAS GOING WAIT
FOR THAT COUNCIL.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT'S THE
CASE.
>> I WONDER, SARAH, IF YOU THINK
THERE ARE GOING TO BE ANY
BOUNDARIES ON TRUMP.
WE'VE SEEN TRUMP HAS SHOWN EVEN
AFTER JANUARY 6th WHERE HE SAW
THE EFFECT THAT HIS LANGUAGE
COULD HAVE, AND HE SAW THE
EFFECT HIS LANGUAGE COULD HAVE
EVEN IN GETTING PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THE CAPITOL.
YOU KNOW, AS IT PERTAINED TO
VIOLENCE.
HE'S SEEN THIS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE WILL BE
ANY BOUNDARIES PLACED ON HIM AS
HE SHOWS THIS PROPENSITY TO USE
LANGUAGE THAT IS QUESTIONABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO VIOLENT?
>> HONESTLY, NOT REALLY.
FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE, ELON MUSK SAID HE DOESN'T
PLAN TO TAKE DOWN A LOT OF
CONTENT BUT LIMIT THE REACH OF
THINGS THAT HE CONSIDERS TO BE
VIOLENCE OR HATE SPEECH.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
MISINFORMATION, I MEAN ELON MUSK
HIMSELF HAS SHOWN A PROPENSITY
TO LEAN INTO CONSPIRACIES,
YOU'LL RECALL HE TWEETED A LINK
TO A FALSE ARTICLE ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI A FEW WEEKS AGO AND
QUICKLY DELETED IT UNDER
ADVERTISER PRESSURE.
I CAN'T SEE HIM GOING AFTER
DONALD TRUMP'S ACCOUNT FOR
THINGS THAT MIGHT BE FALSE OR
MISLEADING.
NOW IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HIS TEAM CONSIDERS TO BE OR HE
CONSIDERS TO BE HATE SPEECH,
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING WHERE HE
SAYS HE WOULD LIMIT THE REACH OF
IT, MEANING ALGORITHMICALLY HE
WOULDN'T BOOST IT IN PEOPLE'S
TIMELINES BUT SAYS HE WON'T
REMOVE THE ACTUAL CONTENT.
>> DO YOU THINK, SARAH, THAT
THIS INCREASES THE CHANCES THAT
FACEBOOK REINSTATES TRUMP, OR DO
YOU THINK THAT FACEBOOK LOOKS AT
WHAT ELON MUSK IS DOING KIND OF
EVEN AGAINST HIS OWN STANDARDS
FOR HOW HE WAS GOING TO LOOK AT
SOME CONTENT AND SAYS MAYBE
THEY'RE NOT GOING REINSTATE
TRUMP?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
I THINK FACEBOOK'S GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT THIS VERY CAREFULLY
AS THEY COME UP AGAINST THEIR
DECISION IN JANUARY.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT FACEBOOK
IS GOING TO BE MAKING THIS
DECISION AND FOR SOME WAYS
INDEPENDENTLY BECAUSE TRUMP USES
A FACEBOOK PLATFORM DIFFERENTLY.
YOU'LL RECALL LEADING UP TO THE
2020 ELECTION AND IN 2016 THAT
TRUMP RELIED HEAVILY ON FACEBOOK
FOR ADVERTISING, ESPECIALLY TO
BUILD LISTS, TO DO FUNDRAISING.
HE DOESN'T REALLY USE TWITTER
LIKE THAT.
TWITTER IS MORE OF A PUBLIC TOWN
SQUARE FOR HIM WHERE HE WOULD
BLAST OUT MESSAGES SO THAT THEY
WOULD GO VIRAL.
I THINK FACEBOOK KNOWS IF THEY
BRING TRUMP BACK, THEY'RE GIVING
HIM A VEHICLE TO DO CAMPAIGNING
THROUGH ADS MORE SO THAN THEY'RE
GIVING HIM A MAJOR PLATFORM FOR
HIS SPEECH.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THIS WILL
CAUSE, SARAH, A MASS EXODUS OF
SOME TWITTER USERS FROM THE
PLATFORM?
>> I CAN'T SAY HOW USERS ARE
GOING TO REACT, ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE ABOUT HALF OF THEM VOTED
TO REINSTATE HIM.
I DO KNOW THAT ADVERTISERS ARE
GOING TO BE VERY SKITTISH ABOUT
THIS DECISION.
I SPOKE WITH ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ADVERTISING AGENCIES LAST WEEK,
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THEY WERE
SAYING IS THAT THEY'RE ISSUING
GUIDANCE TO ADVERTISERS RIGHT
NOW, BUT THAT MANY OF THEIR
CLIENTS ARE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
REMAINING ON THE PLATFORM IF
DONALD TRUMP IS REINSTATED.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH JANUARY 6th OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT DEMOCRACY OR THE
VALIDITY OF THE ELECTIONS IN
2020.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE
REINSTATEMENT OF TRUMP CAN JUST
EXACERBATE SOME OF THE EXODUS
WE'VE SEEN FROM ADVERTISERS TO
DATE.
>> HE'S, YOU KNOW, FIRED, LAID
OFF A LOT OF PEOPLE, ELON MUSK
HAS AT TWITTER, BUT HE'S ALSO
SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DECIDED THEY'RE LEAVING, THEY
DON'T WANT A JOB AT TWITTER WITH
THE WAY HE'S DOING THINGS.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT MORE
EMPLOYEES WILL FOLLOW SUIT AFTER
THIS?
>> I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
I MEAN, TWITTER TENDS TO BE A
VERY PROGRESSIVE COMPANY.
IF YOU LOOK, THERE HAVE BEEN
DATA SHOWN THAT A LOT OF THE
EMPLOYEES HAVE TENDED TO VOTE OR
CONTRIBUTE IN ELECTIONS THAT
MEAN PROGRESSIVE OR DEMOCRAT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE,
THOUGH, WHO HAVE BEEN THERE A
LONG TIME, THEY BELIEVE IN THE
MISSION OF TWITTER.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE TRUMP
THING IS GOING TO MAKE THEM, YOU
KNOW, RUN FOR THE HILLS.
I THINK IT'S ANOTHER DATA POINT
IN ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN HAPPENING THE PAST FEW
WEEKS THAT MAKES CURRENT
EMPLOYEES QUESTION THE DIRECTION
OF THE PLATFORM WRIT LARGE AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK THAT
THIS IS A PLACE THAT'S GOING TO
VALUE THEIR OPINIONS, VALUE THE
INSIGHTS OF THE COMMUNITY, OR
IT'S GOING TO BE A PLACE FOR
ELON MUSK TO SORT OF GOVERN
UNILATERALLY.
>> SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW TO TRUTH
SOCIAL WHICH IS TRUMP'S APP
WHERE HE'S BEEN USING THAT TO
GET HIS MESSAGE OUT THUS FAR?
>> VERY GOOD QUESTION.
SO THERE'S A DECEMBER 8th
DEADLINE FOR TRUTH SOCIAL TO
MERGE WITH ITS BLANK CHECK
COMPANY CALLED THE DIGITAL WORLD
ACQUISITION CORPS.
IF THE SHAREHOLDERS OF THE BLANK
CHECK COMPANY DON'T APPROVE A
MERGER BY DECEMBER 8th,
BASICALLY THE WHOLE THING FALLS
APART.
TRUTH SOCIAL WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
GET THE FUNDING IT WOULD NEED TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
NOW THERE'S ALSO A WEIRD CLAUSE
IN THE TRUTH SOCIAL DOCUMENTS
THAT BASICALLY SAYS THE ASKING
DOESN'T -- DOESN'T HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN THE
SAME WAY IF DONALD TRUMP'S GOING
DECIDE TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
SO I THINK BROADLY SPEAKING IF
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T GET THAT
DECEMBER 8th MERGER VOTE
APPROVED AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
IF HE'S ALLOWED BACK ON TWITTER
AND OTHER SOCIAL PLATFORMS, I
THINK IT'S HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT
TRUTH SOCIAL CONTINUES WITH MUCH
MOMENTUM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS --
YOU KNOW, IF IT SHUTS DOWN OR
NOT.
IT'S N